non-minimalists
what should i do with sentimental items
that other people can't really use like
my personalized high school drill team
letter jacket
it takes up a lot of space but i can't
stand the thought of it taking up space
in a landfill man going back to that
landfill thing
megan uh as soon as you accepted that
jacket in high school
you hurt the environment yeah now that's
not a judgment that's just
stating the fact like the damage has
already been done with that jacket
right and so the narrative we tell
ourselves though is what
and this is what's fascinating about
this question there are two things
obviously this should what should i do
with this jacket and
other people can't really use my
personalized
letter jacket however i was just on a
facetime call with my brother-in-law
he's the youngest sibling of um
bex so bex is the oldest she's 39 and
then from there it goes down to
alec her brother who's i think 29 or or
30 at this point right and he was
wearing
one of her old soccer jackets bex's or
actually
libby her other sister uh old soccer
jackets from
stillwater high school in minnesota and
he was wearing it what a hipster i know
right and so
but what libby could have of course said
well
she could have said what should i do
with the sentimental item that other
that no one else can use well that's
what stories are you what disempowering
stories are you telling yourself
yeah that are preventing you from
letting go self-limiting
beliefs that's the real question to ask
here oh i love that
yeah because it goes back to that quilt
that i was talking about earlier too
there's someone who will find value in
that
letter jacket i promise you yeah yeah
and
certainly more than what you'll find
yeah so don't don't put it in a landfill
so the first thing is
well if i uh i can't donate it because i
don't want to find value on it that's a
self-limiting belief
and then you're telling yourself well
the only option i have is to put it in a
landfill that's another self-limiting
belief
right so um yeah if you really want to
get rid of it and it's going to
free up space in your mind it's going to
uh create a little less anxiety or take
away some anxiety
then go donate it yes i promise you
someone will find that letterman jacket
and be like oh wow look at this
look at this old school letterman jacket
right yeah
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists today